i believe this is
your fourth movie together so over the
course of the last ones were there any
new
techniques or things that you guys knew
you really wanted to try out on this
well you know it's interesting to
mention that because this was the first
movie we've done where you know
melissa was on camera by herself a lot
of times so
um at the beginning of the film so
we leaned heavily on our director of
photography who had the really
interesting
suggestion to see melissa through all
the different devices that she was
talking to
so that it wasn't um you know just like
following her around the house and we
had a little bit more interest in
you know using the camera so that was an
interesting big thing to think about
because
you don't want to just you know i'm
talking to a smoke detector i'm talking
to a tv to a lamp
you know all these different things you
do have to kind of use that camera in a
in a in an active way to keep it
to keep the the pov still interesting so
it was kind of fun to realize
how many different ways we could shoot
that and i did think it worked really
well yeah i thought it was fun
speaking of the pov ben did you have it
mapped out exactly when we would see the
ai's pov or is that something you find
in the edit
i found it in the edit because what we
did was we
really we um we filmed
we we actually used a stills camera to a
video setting
and we we filmed almost everything from
it
in different places so you know we've
got our director of photography again it
was his idea barry peterson
very smart nice guy and uh so we filmed
it from everywhere and then yeah then we
have we could pick and choose the edit
when we wanted to reveal a certain
um when it's really watching her because
it's a voyeuristic movie at the
beginning
because it doesn't feel so different
when it switches to that you
we we are all savvy enough to know when
it goes to like security type
camera feed that somebody's watching
someone that's not supposed to be and it
does elicit
uh like an emotional response yeah we
wanted to kind of ratchet up a little
tension there in the beginning if we
could
um and i think it i think it worked easy
so
melissa another thing i love to ask
about is what a director's tell is
so what does ben do behind the monitor
that
signals to you that he is absolutely
loving what you're doing
he do you see kaboo wait what do you say
did you say yahtzee or kaboom
i have been known to say yahtzee kaboom
he does the thing where he goes
and then he does that and he'll say like
kaboom or etsy
and i sit next to sheila waldron our
long-time script supervisor
uh and uh i you i do a lot of it just to
um
annoy her but also
you probably must know when the scenes
are going well because i laugh at full
volume because i
figured out early on that i can do that
and then the sound uh team
they're so smart and great that they can
take my laughs out as much as they want
so i
i fully laugh through we just we have
such a collaborative way of working that
it's i mean with everybody everybody
who's a part of our things with you know
with bobby or with gene smart or or
brian
who's so fun in this movie it's like
we love working with people that are
going to pitch ideas they're going to be
like what about this what about that and
i think when you stay loose like that
every everybody's kind of
nobody's afraid to put in their good
idea and we always think let's try it
all
let's try it all and then you know you
have the security of editing later but
everybody usually
you feel when it's headed the right
direction sure and i think you know we
were
all those three people that she
mentioned are such strong actors that
you've got the version of the scene that
you need in the first couple of takes
usually you know so um so then you can
you know have
have a little fun play around and you
know kind of you know the actors
discover things as they go which i think
is
one of the joys of creativity right is
to find
what's there that's wonderful steve
mallory wrote a great script so we
we did it and then there's like if
there's an extra moment or an extra
piece or something that someone
discovers that's all about
yeah absolutely so melissa correct me if
i'm wrong on this but i believe you've
been in sequels but you haven't reprised
a role yet so if you had the opportunity
to step back into a character from any
of your movies who would you want to
pick and why
i don't think i've been in the sequel
that's what you yeah
oh sorry i bet you i had that i'm like
you were like in the hangover three yeah
oh gosh i have a weird thing with that
because i really i fall
um wonderfully and terribly in love with
the women i get to play i do really feel
like i get
to know them and then i miss them and i
feel like i still have to kind of like
stand and defend for them um you know
we've talked about a bunch of times
uh re doing another one of spy
just because it was such a fun group
it's
it's it's such a i mean that would be so
incredibly fun
but then i think about like i i do
sometimes think like
where is tammy now like what tammy doing
like where did she i would
love to know like how she's doing i
strangely really
think about that sometimes um i kind of
i've been lucky enough to do a lot of
people that i
really really love and i think if the if
the story was
just and really honest
i think i i don't think i'm not against
uh i'm not against a sequel
i actually really like what's happening
more now than ever that people do it
10 15 years later i think that when you
really are like yeah
that's a long time where is that
character now how is
how they you know is it up or down
that's a
that i think is a could be a cool story
to tell if the time ever comes i would
like to put in a request for
you to revisit your role from the heat
i would do that in a heartbeat set it up
i mean do it like they did lord of the
rings just get paul out there and do
uh do do them both together oh my god i
would use
one of my favorite elements of this
movie that spoke to me probably too much
was the whole uh
dim sum ken griffey jr thing so if you
had the opportunity to swap in
a breakfast food and someone that you
could just have a chat with who would
you pick and why
i don't know that it wouldn't be
dumplings i mean maybe a perfect
truly a perfect food i i will i will
stand behind that
i don't know uh ruth peter ginsberg and
dumplings
uh david bowie and dumplings pizza and
david bowie
pizza and bob dylan pizza flavored
dumplings david bowie and versus
ginsburg and dumplings
all right answers all right answers
there's no one no one's losing here
avocado
toast an rbg that sounds like a good
combo too
thank you guys so much for your time
today